[Music]
on to the next day of testing so we've
got
this all set up so that it can launch as
many windows as we want and currently we
are launching three windows with all
default options they don't do a whole
lot yet but it allows us to test some
base stuff
like i went into the callbacks callbacks
there you are and on this normal mouse
recording i put a c out to show our
mouse position
and this is set for any new window
so let's just have a gander okay we got
one two three windows and we got our
mouse position
showing here in this console out so we
can go over any of these windows
and the mouse position seems to work
okay
but what happens if the window's not
focused like this one over here it still
picks up the mouse position on this
window even if it's not in focus so
that's interesting
uh and what about this one same thing so
it seems to pick it up for any of them
even if they're not in focus but the
first click is going to create an on
focus so i'm not sure how that's going
to get handled or maybe i need to
set this call back to only one at a time
and that's the one on focus
i'm a little i'm a little lost there so
maybe i should use this on focus
callback to set this normal mouse
reporting to the only the current one
uh if it wants to be
if you want to do like a click to
activate
so i'm honestly not sure what's best
but uh
yeah we're gonna be playing around with
this and finding a decent setup
well i guess you know
now that i'm thinking about it we have
in our instance controller
we run through all the updates
so it's going to be processing
the events on all of them even if
they're
not in focus so maybe we only want to
process the one in focus or maybe we
should leave that up to the whoever's
using the library to decide whether
background processes or background
around windows should be updated or not
because it looks like by default they're
going to be updated
all of the windows will be updated
all right that's something to think
about
all right so i've been hacking away at
this code trying some different
instances of
running the windows run all i'll run
single and then i got into theorizing if
a vector or list would be better and i i
think i'm just going to try to get this
done and move on to the next part
without worrying about it i just want to
get it working at this point
i'm kind of tired of messing with the
windows i can always come back to it if
it's good enough because
yeah with run all it's going to work
like it was originally and we can run
single to select which one will run and
it'll ignore all the others
and
maybe we'll add a switcher to switch to
the ones we click in or something like
that we might have to add some more
variables but i'm using static here
because these are controllers
of the entire list of instances
which is held here
that's basically
a singleton
and i don't know if this is better as a
list
i kind of like it as a vector
i'm just worried about how it grows
uh if people add a bunch
of things so
running some test cases
all right so after a lot of work and
toying around i've uh
i've got it to context to just one
window but it's still pulling the mouse
from all of them which i didn't expect
but
currently only one active window
so uh yeah that's uh the new run single
method which is here it's very elaborate
and overdone and over engineered there's
probably a way better way of doing it
than
getting an account and going through the
instances but
i figured i out that i kind of have to
use list here because the way that
vector grows
and
i either need to build some sort of
special move constructor within my
window
which i got gotta research or i can just
use a list for now because
it it grows a lot easier just based on
the
uh the whole method of
basically being a doubly length list
whereas a vector is basically an array
that's got a
copy over everything which calls the
destructor of the window it causes all
kinds of problems so yeah we're just
going to stick with list for right now
until
maybe we figure out move for vector or
is it even worth the performance
difference to worry about all that i
think i'm just going to stick with list
until further notice the only way that
bad that list gets bad is it has no
random access so anytime we want to get
to one of these instances we literally
have to iterate through
the
uh whatever the code
or
iterate through all the lists to get to
it
that's kind of good and bad but the
thing was
and correct me if i'm wrong
this being a vector anyway
made the memory try to be contiguous
which could be weird if stuff is growing
in this instrument instant struct i
don't know how that's going to work
maybe it's better as a list
anyway
because of that too
so yeah uh i don't even know what else i
changed i've been toying around with
this for quite a bit let me just look at
the the get logs
stop this run for a second
okay so the main oh it changed init new
instance to create new window so that's
the new front end
is uh there's no new
indian instance it's now create window
and uh the runs a little different you
can pick a window if you want or if you
leave it blank it's going to do a run
all
so the old method's still in there
we've just added a little more uh this
so what is this okay i just redid the
whole create window
they now call static helper functions or
static control functions on the instance
so that way this doesn't
we don't need to have the list in this
class the list of instance is static
in the instance cpp which means
no other class can ever touch it
it's self-managed here
and
that should keep it pretty clean
because that's not something i want all
over
the code base uh just one spot basically
and uh
yeah just to straighten up the header a
little bit i i need to make this private
but there's some
some kind of glitch
because i don't want people
instantiating instances it's all
static controlled so
uh yeah i need to make this private and
this a new window should be able to do
it because it's a member class
but it doesn't seem to be able to do if
it's private so i got to research that
and let's see what is this one the
callbacks
um oh yeah i was just doing testing on
the mouse position nothing big there
and let's see yeah that's pretty much
everything i've changed i went ahead and
bumped this up the standard
11 c plus plus standard or 11 17
because 17
has a function that we want to use
rather than have to rewrite a bunch of
stuff
and that is remove if
let's remove if is going to be nice for
the run all speaking of actually need to
test that
so let's just go to this main here
and
change that to blank and now that's
going to do a run all and let's just
make sure the window is closed correctly
okay we should get a bunch of windows
popping up oh i got a stop point there
okay there we go a bunch of windows now
they should all close correct oh
okay so now we've introduced some new
error
the remove if is not working basically i
think
well
okay i just had the wrong remove if in
here for a list so
uh we can get rid of this range it
automatically just
does the whole range if they're marked
for deletion remove them okay that
should take care of it at least i hope
that was it pretty sure it's hit
uh it's just a little thing there i had
to change that
to adapt to a vector
and let's see yep that's better very
good
okay so a quick talk on that let's see
where was that the ray
uh
it's in here
yeah the remove if so this one comes
from the list header
so you
list has a remove if function but vector
does not have a remove if function
that's an algorithm so you need
algorithm if you're using vector
and you got to do it the way i showed
before but lists just has it built in so
another
little difference there and that's where
that bug came from because i hadn't
changed this back properly
all right well it's been a pretty
interesting day of coding i've actually
uh hammered out a few things that were
pretty important
so that's probably going to do for today
peace out guys
[Music]
you